Tyree Nichols first time you saw it what
was your reaction first you heard the
story then when they released the video
actually it was not shocked in fact
um they described it as worse than
Rodney King and I thought that
um but when I saw it and I'm and again I
had his daughter Rodney King's Daughter
on my show
I'm not comparing the two it wasn't as
worse as Rodney King but it was still it
was still pathetically awful Rodney King
lived
Tyree Nichols died three days later but
Rodney King also died early because of
the massive trauma he sustained the head
trauma uh and had physical physical
ailments of the rest of his life so
but the thing I also realize is why that
didn't shock me folks like it were black
cops I'm like oh y'all thought it was a
black white thing it's always been a
blue thing
always been a blue thing
because we have to deal with what
happens in police departments
I've talked to too many chiefs who are
gross who are greatly frustrated because
people think oh change the police chief
you know anything in the company you can
be the CEO give an order
with your middle management
Don't Force It to happen and the next
level doesn't happen we have to con and
all this oh we got good you know good
apples and bad apples it's BS because
what's the fundamental thing that
happens in police departments I ain't
gonna what do they say let's get rid of
stop snitching the greatest the greatest
don't snitch is in police departments
cops are scared cops won't come forward
to call another cop out because they'll
get ostracized
that's a that's an issue I've long said
if you have body cameras and dash cams
if that cop turns it off or doesn't turn
it on automatic firing
why are you turning it off
why you're not turning it on in Chicago
they were breaking the antennas off of
the dash cams uh so it wouldn't record
yeah
it's cops are doing that
why did Anita Alvarez and why actually
why Lord life get elected because they
held that laquan McDonald tape for a
whole damn year knowing the cops were
lying knowing knowing they were lying
and that video was released we actually
saw so we see too often in this country
where cops are lying on police reports
look at the Tyree Nichols police report
oh he was he was sweaty profusely he was
abusive
they would see the body cam footage so
what does that tell you when you see
case of the case of the case of the case
of cops lying on reports the body camera
video showing this here
yeah it was systemic problem
and then the answer isn't just hey let's
have more training no I believe was
retired LAPD Sergeant Cheryl Dorsey said
there's got to be annual she says every
two year mental evaluations of police
officers
there are people they got a badge and a
Gun Man the power that they have
think about it they have the power to
literally take your life
and go back to work I believe you got
that kind of power that comes with great
responsibility and I don't play around
with that and it's just it we've got to
deal with this here because last year
the the most people killed by cops uh in
history was last year
why how do we change it how do we fix it
how do how do we change somebody the
white guy who's partially blind coming
from jury duty and they walk up to him I
think I was here in Florida I think and
like you got a weapon you know I I got
my my blind stick and they literally
arrest the dude
he was just coming from jury duty there
are cops that abuse their power we gotta
deal with that and we got to be honest
about it yeah I was uh I was a victim of
police brutality when I was I want to
say 16 years old Halloween you know
hands on the car and I remember seeing
hands on the car mistaken identity the
rookie comes out of the car kicks my
ankle and almost breaks my ankle I agree
with the the only thing that sucks when
you come to this is there's they're
human beings at the end of the day so
when we have I don't know let's say how
many cops are in America I'm just I'm
talking about let's say five million
right in that 5 million I don't care how
much we're gonna do and how much gonna
train the human element is still there
which yes it just sucks unless we're
gonna have robots at some point yeah you
have the human element yes but what we
have to do is stop acting like well I
think it was a Connecticut
this is the video he's get on your knees
he's literally his hands up he's going
on his knees cops rear back
kicks him in the head knocks him
unconscious I saw that go to trial not
guilty yep
you're like
wait I'm sorry
yeah
and so what happens is so what happens
is and I can tell you being in Chicago
for six years
when they came in the Justice Department
cops are like oh yeah
yeah we regularly will call you the
n-word
yeah we wrecked they admitted yeah we
would pick up a gang member and we would
drop them off in a rival neighborhood uh
just to see what happens
okay I know you think it's a game and
what the hell the Holman Street facility
where lawyers didn't even know that
their clients were being held
you're like that's why I'm talking about
China it's like what the hell when
Chicago had to pay out 40 million in
reparations because John Bird you know
took Vietnam era tactics and was
attaching electrical cords to the
testicles of these men to force
confessions and they knew it all of
these years these guys were sitting in
prison
for 10 and 15 20 years and a newest
fourth confession that was a judge in
Chicago a couple years ago uh it was a
year ago
he got so pissed
he had eight cops who were flat out
lying the judge went to the police
accountability board and said these cops
are flat out lying on the witness stand
the judge was so offended that's why Kim
Fox that's why uh uh Sharon Brave boy in
in Prince George they literally say
these cops will NE we will not
they will never take the stand
because they are known lies now so again
somebody would say well rolling you know
look it's not all cops
but you don't want your kid to be on the
receiving end of that lion cop that is
what has to change in this country the
problem is folks like well you know but
you know just a few you're like a few
Clevelands under its second consent
decree in 10 years dude what what the
hell
and again that is a it is a power you
know what I like the most you know what
I like how are things what I think by
the way there is the power thing I had a
friend of mine who was a cop who was the
sweetest guy when he became a cop every
year he got more and more and more and
more like uh you know let me tell you
who I am and all this stuff I'm like you
know what I said one thing I sound God
said listen you're not the same guy I
said I don't like the way you're talking
to a girl you seem like a little too
hardcore right now this wasn't you you
were the sweetest guy we had here and
finally he got fired he literally got
fired but the reason why he got fired
was for a different reason was for
steroids but he got fired and yeah that
probably added to the hell that product
not explaining it not using it oh
Distributing it distribution oh God yeah
yeah so anyway so it didn't work out
okay and he got out
and we'd have the conversation I think
the best thing that if you think about
accountability wise the last 10 years
when it comes down to issues like this
no invention has been more to hold
everybody accountable than camera phones
think about what that's done the fact
that you are able to record and you see
the story and the camera on the cops I'd
say that's well we all getting a lot
better I mean the first police
department was it was real to California
and when they went to buy the camera
body cameras there was a 70s I think was
like a 77 percent drop in the number of
um reports filed against cop for police
abuse
and it was a drop in the number of
reports of the cops claiming folks were
attacking them yes because you get the
cameras right I love that the pro the
the problem the problem that we still so
so but here's the deal but the cameras
are not the Panacea they are a tool but
what's not would you say about the phone
but what's not happening in various
States like Arizona oh we're going to
pass laws you can't record us
see now it's like now it's a or or no no
what do they say their reason is it's
it's always a BS reason but we know why
what happens is you don't want to get
recorded and so and look it was and we
talk about the power of the phone yeah
I'm flying I'm flying I don't know where
the hell are flying I'm going through
Chicago
that's a that's a uh uh shoeshine stand
but no person is there so this guy is
sitting like on the on the work wait
that shot in the shoe I got you sitting
there we're sitting in one of the seats
yeah so like he's on FaceTime I think
with his wife or daughter or somebody so
I walk up I said excuse me I'm gonna
take a seat [__] you Jesus no you're not
sitting down here [__] you
I go excuse me
I go
I'm sorry who are you talking to
he stands up you're not [__] sitting
here
I'll go
let me get airport police
I said I'm not about dealing with you
today and so then well okay and so he
goes
I said let me explain something to you
you're lucky I have all of the grace of
Jesus today
I said I could have pulled my phone out
and I could have made your ass real
popular in 30 seconds do you know how
lucky you are today
but well I said no no no I want you to
understand now mind you while I'm
talking
hey Roland love your work hey bro black
guy come white guy walk by what hey what
he so he now all of a sudden he's like I
said
do you understand I got four million
followers
you almost lost your job today
no no no
you need to ask yourself why did you
decide to just to cuss me out say you
lucky I didn't pull my two phones out
there's a lot of these places they don't
want people recording because they don't
want the truth and that's my problem
with the build now you want to say hey
you can't be in three feet that's fine
yeah because you're saying you're it no
that's not what a lot of these folks are
trying to do they don't want this is
Arizona I think it's Arizona is it past
uh yeah oh it passed and more states are
looking at that because they don't want
that accountability and it's increasing
and again
I've supported by the cameras but I've
also said
if you're a cop the moment you get in
that car click it's on everything's
recorded I don't know if y'all saw the
story where the cops didn't realize they
buy the cameras on and they were
stealing money oh yeah I just saw that
yeah and they were they went oh [__]
yeah it's already true it's a wrap well
that's how uh I think was insane the
female cop she was busted using the
n-word because the body cam was recorded
yeah okay and again I just say I just
simply say if you turn it on it's eight
months it's eight feet of the police
yeah that's what because at that point
because well you can record they just
don't want you yeah I agree because no
no but though some states were actually
talking about blocking people from
accidents that's ridiculous it's
interfering with their police official
police duty that to me I'm saying that's
wrong yeah there has to be
accountability I think I think camera is
keeping all of us honest and uh but the
problem is after you may have that video
yeah
but still
now you got to get to
is the da going to take it to the Grand
Jury
because it's a lot of DA's don't want to
pitch yeah but you know you know what's
changed and then you go they say let's
say you do go to trial like the
Connecticut start yeah there have been
examples where you're sitting at home
going
look I don't know how in the hell this
guy's gonna get off but a jury is
because in this country
we give
so much authority to police
so much Authority police that people
the human part
which is why and a lot of times
the charge will get downgraded by the
jury
yeah I'm not we're not comfortable
convicting them on first degree or
second degree murder so let's take it
out a manslaughter and so we still have
this thing in America here
yeah but but it's the cops you know I
disagree let me let me tell you why
juries have said it no no I understand
jury said it but here's the problem
here's the progress my my biggest thing
is progress I think we're making a lot
of progress they're making a lot of
progress hold up why I'll tell you I
think we're making a lot of progress
because
um it's preventing both sides to make up
any stories okay so say the jury says
now we're not going to do no problem
just post it on Facebook Hold Up post it
on Facebook post it on Twitter it gets
Millions on top of millions but it
doesn't matter though if we see the
video again I'm using an example we see
the video it gets posted
they go to trial it's found not guilty
and you're going how did you how did
y'all see what were y'all looking at
and so then it becomes that person was
never held accountable then it becomes
like Tamir rice that's areas we need to
that's areas no no but I but I asked you
you said you said it's improving but why
wait so to ask me the question why not
you're saying it's not no no no no no no
no no I'm not saying that why is it
improving I'm saying I give you my
answer go ahead what do you think it is
because publicly you can't deny what we
saw when the video came out for Tyree
Nichols it that day nobody was a
republican Democrat independent because
here's the deal here's the deal examples
like that yeah it just flat out but but
like even the Fraternal Order police
released a statement which they never do
here's actually why it's gotten better
because I'm about to drive you crazy
it's gotten better because like foot no
because because of activists on the
ground
that have been demanding accountability
no no no see no you said antifa that
have been demanding accountability that
have been going to those City Council
meetings those State legislatures and
yeah and we started throwing out
hardcore right-wing prosecutors and you
begin to have prosecutors no no no so
that's why no no I'm trying to tell you
can you please send those activists to
those 27 cities I'm trying to tell you
first of all first of all you clearly
don't understand about Chicago because
they've been on lightfoot's ads from day
one yeah what I'm what I'm saying is
what I'm saying is activists she gets
reelected because of the politician dude
first of all the polling right now shows
in fourth place I know I saw that so
which was good yeah but it's good she's
so she's done I know what's happening on
the ground in Chicago you ain't
understand that here's the deal
activists have played a role in changing
public perception
a huge huge role and so we cannot I I we
I love people who want to deny the role
of activism and Marxism protesting but
that's a huge reason why Republicans
don't hurt your cities and go into you
know Louis Vuitton stores and anything
like that if you don't do that go for it
keep doing it well here's you know what
I like about what Tyree Nichols mom said
here's what I like about what Tyree
Nichols mom said she said
protest but please don't hurt our cities
dude we understand all that what a great
thing she said duh but how about this
how about this here don't kill somebody
so we don't even get to that
see I love folk who love say oh my God
uh uh don't tearing thing down to burn
anything down how about you don't uh
kill anybody because here's the one
thing here you can you can run this here
we go and surprising I also please I
don't think you will do I know what you
could do you do you know what was the
precursor to nearly every ride in the
60s
tell me police violence okay nearly
every single one Jimmy Jackson and Selma
yeah killed by cops when you look at
what happened uh in uh Detroit what
happened L.A what happened to Harlem
it's 2023. no no no no no no no no no
I'm giving you historical I'm trying to
walk you through
what what preceded the riots in nearly
every case it was police violence
even Dr King when he went to L.A after
the Watts Riots he thought Oh I thought
Los Angeles was the land of golden
opportunity he did not realize how deep
the racism was in Los Angeles what I'm
saying is we we should be thankful for
the people who took to the streets the
activists uh the folks who rallied
around black lives matter right the
people who the people the people who uh
organized and protested because the
system has to change and the system only
changes when the people put pressure on
the system can if the activists are
listening please go to those 27 cities
and demand change
because they also have to go to those
they need help serious those same
activities contact First friend
go to them so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign